when you write a fraction there are
actually words for the top number and
the bottom number and the words are a
lot more fancy than the word top number
and bottom number well what
mathematicians typically use is the word
numerator
numerator for the top number and
denominator for the bottom number
denominator
denominator for the bottom number now
what i want to do now now that we know
that the top number is the numerator of
the fraction the bottom number is the
denominator i want to compare pairs of
fractions that have either the same
denominator or the same numerator so
let's look at this first pair i want to
compare four sevenths to three sevenths
and i have two holes right over here
they're the same whole and i've divided
them into sevens i've divided them into
seven equal chunks and i want to see
what's larger four sevens or three
sevens so what i can do is i can fill in
four sevenths let me select four out of
the seven
so that's one
two
three
four
and the fact that trying to even get to
four sevens i had to have three sevenths
first gives you a good clue that four
sevenths is probably larger or it is
larger but now let's color in three
sevenths just so we can compare so one
two
three
sevens and so it's pretty clear that on
the left-hand side we are sharing we are
shading in
more of the whole than on the right-hand
side so 4 7 represents a larger fraction
more of the whole than 3 7. and the way
that we can state that comparison
mathematically is with the greater than
symbol we can write 4 7 is greater than
is greater than 3 7. now the greater
than and less than symbols can sometimes
be confusing this is greater than this
is less than so this is greater than
greater than
this is less than
and the way that i remember it is that
the greater than symbol either symbol
the small pointy side is always on the
side of the smaller number and the big
open side is always on the side of the
larger number so here big open side is
opening towards the 4 7 small pointy
side opening to the 3
four sevenths is greater than three
sevenths
now what about three sevenths and three
fourths so here i have different
denominators but i have the same
numerator and so i encourage you to
pause this video and draw maybe a little
boxes like this and try to judge for
yourself which of these is a larger
fraction is it represents a larger
number
well let's color them in
so let's think about 3 7 first and we
actually already drew it here but i
could do it really fast right over here
so that is three sevens i've colored in
three
of the seven equal groups and what would
three fourths be well that's one fourth
two fourths
and three
and so it's pretty clear that
three-fourths represents a larger
fraction of the whole that three-fourths
is larger or that three-sevenths is
smaller so we could write that
three-sevenths is less than
4. so notice same exact numerator when i
divided it because this fraction symbol
could also be viewed as division when i
have it as more equal groups or it's a
fraction of more equal groups so 3 out
of 7 versus 3 out of 4 this is a smaller
number which which makes sense
now let's compare these two we have the
same denominator different numerators
three-fourths versus two-fourths
well three-fourths we've already looked
at we can just shade in three of these
so three of these fourths
so that's three fourths right over there
and then two fourths where we're going
to only have two of the fourths one
two so two fourths is clearly the
smaller number three fourths is the
greater number so once again we could
write three-fourths is greater than
two-fourths
and then finally i encourage you to
pause the video try to come up with a
whether two-fourths or three-sixths is a
larger number
well let's color it in again
we've already seen two fourths we just
have to color in two of our fourths
so let's just color in two of our
fourths right over there
and then 3 6
we've split our hole into three into six
equal sections one two three four five
six we need to color in three of them
we need to color in three of them and as
you see we are coloring coloring in the
exact same amount of the whole these two
fractions are equivalent
these are equivalent fractions 2 4 is
equal to 3 6. and as you see here
they're both filling in half of the hole
if we were to just draw the hole and
split it only let me do this in a
different color
if we have our hole so our hole and we
were to split it only into two sections
only into two sections we are shading in
exactly one out of the two sections
one out of the two sections so you could
say
you could say that two-fourths is equal
to three-sixths and they both equal
one-half they all equal so one-half is
equal to two-fourths is equal to
three-sixths